[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
alors le look c'est très important pour
vous le look ccc oui c'est le look c'est
tout ce que vous avez en tant qu'artiste
vous devez avoir votre propre look un
look distinctif en pantalon d'homme
cette chaussure to give away ya soeur et
fourmies a montré avec plaisir il y en a
dans ma loge la mémoire pantalon c'est
pour moi j'ai vu on est à peu près dans
la même dans le même temps ça ça c'est
plate à ces magnifiques le collier bamba
une maison c'est complètement oasis à le
collier discret cet album c'est la
maison et devrait dire un 100m et
regarder dedans d'adopter mais oui tu
ouvres comme ça et puisque des mailings
en fait et quand ou bien un mec qui te
brasseur a tu veux que j'essaye je vous
explique il a donné libre
[Applaudissements]
thank you might like là c'est une
fortune fac des cris thank you est
choqué youla de remonter l'eau monter
des escaliers
ah oui il faut que je montre les escales
où la maison en fait est ce qu'on peut
appeler stéphane plaza pour faire bien
accueilli à cannes jean franchement
j'adore c'est mon style a offert par
contraire si t'as pas une minerve le
lendemain je vais t'aider à merci et
surtout qu'est new inquiète deux heures
can you help me ht hc n'a acheté à
waldhambach hockey la schlague j'ai mis
à l'envers
alain bernard est sûrement la brute à
wes ans alors il faut savoir que
[Applaudissements]
sa voix rauque et je suis sûr que cette
maison-là les plus chers que la maison
qu'on a offert est les plus chers comme
un mélo mais nous ça veut dire tard et
que tu as reach the roots ragga femme
chérie c'est bon j'ai acheté deux
maisons pour le foyer on tient on a eu
le pré
celle c'est bon on a le prêt on va voir
la butte et oulémas faryab
la toile est faux ilike high life with
c'est qui qui fait sa maison phénix
rajjou c'est à new york
c'est quoi la mobilité sociale est liée
à un l et il y attend t elle new york et
car je dois citer d'autres marques de
bijoux
bon bah c'est erroné vignon délit d'
harry tati or voilà et je sens que cette
leçon comme cet imam bien mais il est
quand même en petites ombres
j'ai quand même sa maison j'ai quand
même si bart autour du cou là je suis
comme ça ça veut dire aux me braque
frère c'est non il est en train de se
dire le mec matin le monde alors of 7
on a voulu préparer un défilé pour toi
il ya des jeunes filles qui vont défiler
tu va nous dire laquelle laquelle tu
préfères laquelle quel look tu préfères
puisque elles ont préparé des looks
assez incroyable alors et celle que tu
préférera est-ce que tu il paraît que tu
veut l'amener avec toi à la aux états
unis celle que tu vas préféré dans l'est
dans le look vérité non d'accord merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que les appels de grandes choses
one alors on y va
premier modèle c'est parti on y va
regarder et ne veut plus des filets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kelly mais novelli qui défilent
normalement pour le salon du chocolat
mais la dame à la rituelle dessine pour
le salon du chocolat mais l'aide à la
fois la bouffe et sa robe comme avoir la
foi la bouffe et sa robe elle préfère
filer comme ça du lac
merci là c'est le maintien
j'adore la vesper satchi c'est cool tu
es ma came toutes les marques versace
est illettrée you are
entrée 12 e ass est très beau ça
franchement bravo bravo que ça vous va
très bien attention elle a été plus
beaux élue plus belle femme de france en
regardez c'est delphine wespiser
[Applaudissements]
on venait d'un marathon j'ai eu la même
chose de faire une version de la part de
michael jackson à l'époque il vous a
offert ça ouais
essart et nous on s'offre des puissances
catherine sarezza ton anniversaire
regardez trop la maca elle est venue
spécialement du sud de la france juste
pour défiler pour vous dire qu'elle a
pas beaucoup de travail on la surnomme
morzini dans le monde entier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait elle a juste mis des colliers sa
vie ici à vous donner des coups à l'est
pas c'est apparemment avait passé au bhv
vers ce qu'on a avec nous un dernier
modèle que vous allez s'en occuper mais
c'est un autre style totalement un autre
délire c'est isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jours
alors allez par isabelle olafsson à
toutes les tenues sont cool ap mais je
pense que ces banques est la meilleure
tenue
[Applaudissements]